the URI matcher we just coded is central
to coding our content provider and will
be used in the implementation of our
core content provider methods we've
given you tests to help you along the
way as you code weather provider since
several of these tests have been
repurposed from the database tests you
helped write you may want to look at how
the content provider calls replace the
SQLite database calls in tests such as
test location table and test weather
table but before we can start
implementing step four and testing our
content provider we need to register it
in the Android manifest so that Android
knows about it once the weather provider
has been registered with the package
manager we can use an android utility
class called the content resolver to
refer to it the content resolver locates
our class using the content authority
and makes direct calls to the weather
provider on our behalf add a provider
tag into the androidmanifest.xml file to
register the weather provider class with
the content authority as defined in the
weather contract
note that the two fields you need to
populate in the provider tag are android
: name and android : authority uncomment
the test provider registry test within
test provider to test to see if you've
done this correctly